hello and welcome to deep dive the
podcast that delves into the minds of
entrepreneurs creators and other
inspiring people to uncover their
journeys towards finding joy and
fulfillment at work and in life my name
is ali and in each episode i chat to my
guests about the philosophies strategies
and tools that have helped them along
the path to living a life of happiness
and meaning this week i chatted to
youtuber content creator and now
best-selling author jade in the episode
we have a very productive conversation
about finding balance within hustle
culture motivation book writing
reshaping the definition of career the
law of attraction opinions around toxic
productivity and much much more you know
we love a side hustle it's great but not
at the detriment of
killing yourself in the process you'll
leave this episode with techniques for
living with intention including jade's
hashtag a casual magic mantra a ton of
study techniques and productivity hacks
and a little more perspective about what
it really means to live a productive and
meaningful life and career
jade how you doing welcome to the
podcast i'm doing good thank you for
having me
this is so strange because i have seen
this setup for years and now here i am
here we are yeah last time we spoke was
about a year ago yeah maybe more than a
year ago
um on like a live stream and so this is
the first time we're meeting in the
flesh i know you're in 3d me in 3d yeah
and you've been kind of jet setting all
around the world like korea and san
francisco and berlin and stuff and now
you're in the uk for a few weeks yeah we
found time fun time to do this thing
how has all the traveling been
oh gosh yeah so i studied in south korea
last semester which was amazing like uh
just so culturally different
but it was so nice being able to
experience with all my uni friends as
well awesome um i feel like
also some people watching this or
listening to this might not know who you
are so i wonder if we do a quick kind of
dive into your backstory and then we'll
come along to talking about this this
bad boy
um the book it's such a pretty book it's
like so nice it's like so well done but
we'll gush about the book in a moment
how would you describe what you do if
someone asks you like you're at a party
or something someone's like so what do
you what do you do how do you how do you
answer that question oh that's a tough
question it's a tough question yeah oh
um i say so i make videos
just short answer long answer um so i
guess i started in a space of youtube
called studytube i feel like most of you
are very familiar with studytube in the
productivity space
yeah and kind of talking about my
journey of gcses and a-levels things
that helped me study tips productivity
advice all of that good stuff
and then i took a gap year and i vlogged
my travels and my journey there and i
think especially as someone who
was always you know very into academics
it was a big leap out of my comfort zone
and my gap year so it was cool taking
people along that journey and now that
i'm at university i make study content
about that but it also follows just my
life and living with intention and yeah
trying to trying to inspire people to
love themselves go out their comfort
zone that kind of thing
that's a pretty good a pretty good like
pitch the trying to inspire people to
love themselves get outside their
comfort zone has it has it always been
that
like since you started the channel or it
has the sort of the thing that you're
trying to inspire people to do has that
evolved over time yeah um i think when i
first started just in the study space it
was a lot more niche the goal was you
know just trying to help people feel
less stressed about school
so whether that was equipping them with
more tools you know study techniques
trying to reduce the stress that you
feel when you've got an exam coming up
but over time it's definitely evolved to
be more holistic about you as a human as
deep as that sounds like i like to talk
about things like
loneliness and all these struggles that
we find perfectionism fear of failure
yeah and i guess school is one element
of that but now it's more holistic how
do you decide what you want to talk
about um okay so i have like a brain
dump place on my notion no love notion
same thing
so good can i have it on my phone i
haven't my laptop and whenever i have a
random idea or write a book or listen to
a podcast that just sparks something
i'll just drop it there and then i kind
of i think similar to you i have a
camping board and i sort of drag ideas
they're like okay this is like an actual
idea and whenever i have a dull moment i
sit and sort of script it out and then
when i come to film i sort of just
select from these scripts i've already
got how do you think about this balance
between
will this video perform well on the
stats versus is this a video that i want
to make personally
oh it's a tough one um because i think
as you start to do youtube you
definitely know what will do better and
worse
i i start to think about value and
impact um in less just a numerical sense
but also thinking okay this might be a
really niche topic but if you watch this
and you got a lot of value from it like
that should mean more to me than just
you know like 200k views so it's kind of
this balance between what i really like
making what i think will
create the most impact but not
necessarily be the most like widely
reaching and then a few videos which
get some new people in i guess
that's a pretty good way of looking
about it looking at it i've kind of been
thinking similarly as well like we were
having a content planning brainstorming
session this morning and there were a
couple of videos where i was like i know
the video is not going to do well yeah
but i know it's like a good video to
make and it's the sort of video that i
want to make because it's like the right
the right sort of impact so it's cool
that you're also thinking in those terms
because i feel like we've both been
doing youtube for like four and a half
years now yes um and so i i feel like
for me definitely at the start it was a
i just need to get videos out and decide
for sure yeah and like almost make a
name for yourself too like views that
seem the most important no exactly and
then i i think for me about a year or
two i was like oh i became like numbers
focused thinking about the algorithm a
lot and now i'm kind of like in a stage
where i'm trying not to think about the
algorithm as much as possible yeah no i
think you've got a good thing going too
because you post so much content that
like the perfectionism about it changes
right you're just like just post you
know it's got to be done yeah and
especially for posting like three videos
then not all three of those videos needs
to go viral right so then it allows you
to play around more and just do stuff
that makes you happy but yeah so your
your strategy for youtube in the early
days is quite interesting and i often
use you as an example when i'm speaking
to other
other kind of like wannabe youtubers
where one approach to youtube is just
like make a load of stuff and you'll be
really bad initially and you'll get good
over your first 100 videos and then you
can start thinking about what to make
stuff about
but when we last perk you said that your
approach was a little bit different can
you can you tell us a little bit about
what was your approach to youtube back
in the day in 2017 yes um
okay so i think i had this thing in my
head similar to being a study person was
i need to study youtube a bit before i
just dive right in
and so i chose this arbitrary date in
the future it's two months down the line
february 17th i still remember and
between now and february 17th i am going
to teach myself how to edit i'm going to
learn a little bit about seo
optimization all these things i knew
nothing about i'm going to go on youtube
on the creator side and do some learning
there
and i feel like that gave me a lot of
confidence in not only the kind of
content i wanted to make but also felt
like okay cool like i can make videos
that hopefully someone will want to
watch and obviously you do learn a lot
through the journey but my approach was
sort of work that out beforehand yeah
and how did that go in in the early days
quite well i think i got quite lucky
though because i found this niche of
youtube where
like people clearly wanted it but it
wasn't really a thing yet um so my first
few videos obviously they got like 50
views like literally nothing um but i
was already getting comments from people
saying that there was about like value
here and that was something that made me
know i was on the right track and then
in april of that year i went from 400
subscribers to 10 000 in a week
which is very rare and i know
and it was like my embarrassing little
channel that i had suddenly became like
oh wow like she actually has a channel
now so from 400 subscribers to 10 000 in
a week yeah and what did that feel like
oh my god it was
insane because i was on the easter
holidays and i was in year 12. so you
know i go on to the easter holidays and
i'd have an embarrassing channel and
then i come back and all of a sudden
people just know about it my
embarrassing channel and and i had a
camera like my chemistry teacher came up
to me and she was like
we've all watched your videos in the
staff room
and
that was like a very remote for me being
like wow like god people are seeing me
in my bedroom at home like even my
teachers
um yeah it was very weird like hard to
process i'm not sure and did you have
any sort of background in video stuff or
was it like completely self-taught no
completely self-taught but that's the
beauty of youtube is you can learn from
youtube yeah and the the thing about
embarrassing channel like how did how
did you
because
even today it's kind of cringy having a
youtube channel especially in the early
days yeah yeah because we idolize
youtube no exactly yeah and like i've
spoken to so many people who spend a lot
of time on tech talk and if i've asked
them have you thought about creating a
tech talk oh gosh i could never do that
and if i dig down it's often uh
embarrassment and cringe are the two
words that that come up but you refer to
your channel as like your embarrassing
channel but you but you did it anyway so
like how were you thinking about like
the embarrassment cringe factor of
having a youtube channel
early on okay so i have a theory that if
you hide it it gives people a reason to
make fun of it because it's like if
you're trying to hide it then clearly
it's there's something embarrassing
about it
so i did the opposite i remember i put
on my instagram page which was just full
of like friends and family oh hey guys
i'm starting this youtube channel and
i'm really proud of it and that sort of
means people can't touch it now because
i'm claiming that i'm proud of it yes
and it would be mean for them to then be
like exactly
yep and so i think the more that you can
own it even if secretly you feel
embarrassed the less people can say
anything negative about it okay so you
just pretend like you're totally cool
with it and like act like
proud and all that kind of stuff
did you get much kind of hate back in
the day
oh my god do you know what my first ever
piece of hate was
it's all so stupid now that i say it and
so someone said that i look like a horse
which i was going to end differently
like oh like you have such a horse face
which would have been fine right like
receiving that once but then they
started commenting on every single video
like oh hey horse face like oh your nose
just looks like a horse
and it actually really got to me and i
remember
i would like look at myself in the
mirror and be like do i look like a
horse
um yeah so i think you know when you're
not accustomed to receiving online hate
it's like anything mildly negative is
really new and weird
but yeah i think over time you numb
yourself to it
yeah so it's it's four years on now your
channel is like absolutely enormous and
like ridiculously successful by any sort
of reasonable metrics um how do you
think about the hate aspect of it these
days like do you get much hate these
days i think it like fluctuates yeah but
of course it's always going to be there
it's been there since the start less
horse face comments yeah
um yeah i think
part of it is like just thinking about
all the positive people that you're
impacting and
trying to like remember in those moments
where you get you know 10 comments which
are hateful that you have a thousand of
people who whose life you changed whose
day you changed who you made smile or
any any of these moments um yeah like
that stuff is more important but then
the brain just is it's not great is it
because it's so funny you can get a
thousand of those comments and you don't
remember them like you do that one bad
one so i think it depends on my own
mental state
like if i'm really stressed at uni or
other things are going on about in my
life i find it affects me a lot more
whereas if i'm in a really good state
then it's like well
shut up
yeah i know what you mean it's it's kind
of the same for me i think if the first
few years i like i didn't really get
many hate comments at all and when i
would it would just kind of be funny but
recently there have been like quite a
few like very specifically targeted ones
where i sort of feel like it is starting
to affect me and it is often related to
what else is going on in life yeah for
sure do you tend to reply to them or
block them or leave it what's your
strategy i will i would never reply to
that like occasionally i would like hot
them and stick them on my instagram oh
yeah that's quite funny if they're funny
uh but the ones that are like really
sort of close to the boat yeah yeah i
tend to just kind of look at it and then
i'll ignore it um i was speaking to a
few other youtuber friends who get far
more hit comments on like tech videos
and things
and they just delete them and like hide
the user from their channel so like they
can still the user can still comment and
still see their own comments but no one
else sees their comments yeah um and i
like initially i thought that that's a
bit of a weird strategy like why
wouldn't you want the hate comments on
the videos then these guys were saying
that like
like
99.99 of the comments are really nice
and most people will scroll down the
comments and see what's going on yeah
and like even if someone wasn't thinking
something negative about a video if they
see a negative comment about you or
about the video it will color their
impression of you and so true and stuff
it's like giving someone a new lens to
see you through and so like this the
strategy is like yeah if you notice
anything negative just like delete it
and i've been doing that recently and
it's like whoa is it creating it's
freeing it's like i can't just delete
this comment and then i have to worry
about it
that's so cool it's like you're taking
the power back you're like this is my
comment section yeah i can do what i
want yeah you want that's awesome um so
we're we're we're four years in and
while at university while doing youtube
you found the time to write and publish
a book yes
how like what was that how did how did
this how did this start
yeah okay um god should we go back to
the beginning let's go back to the
beginning was it august 2020
yes although before that i'd always
wanted to write a book in this space
actually the first job i ever wanted to
have was to be an author but a fiction
so i've always loved writing i wrote
what bad fanfiction oh hello i was that
person uh link in the video description
no no thank you um oh my god it's so
tragic i read it back the other day yeah
it's embarrassing what are we writing
fanfiction about
if i say i know people are gonna go find
it but
but it was a cross between the divergent
and the hunger games okay nice yeah but
with like more saucy elements okay
no i'm kidding same characters yeah no
some it was like a follow-on it was like
the kids of some of the characters oh
mm-hmm interesting and i guess there was
some kind of love story in there
somewhere oh you've got to have some
romance i had no romance in my life at
like 14 so it's just like i would live
it through my fanfiction
and you know i i'd name all the
characters after my friends in real life
and then this is just like the most
indirect non-controversial way of
dealing with uh friendships but if
something was going wrong in a
relationship in real life i could just
kill off a character with this
so we were writing like a series of fan
fiction um no it was just one really
long fanfiction of like a hundred
thousand words bloody hell yeah
wow okay
i was like every morning before school i
would just write another chapter for all
my fans
and people were reading this stuff and
yeah when you were 14. yeah how how does
that work like i have zero experience
with the side of the world at all
yeah no what pad is amazing okay yeah so
it's it's got it's kind of like a social
media
of books okay so you you decide to
create a story and then you like publish
a chapter and then you just keep
publishing them and people can follow
along the story and be like oh hey like
waiting for the next chapter wow this
chapter was amazing and then you can say
oh every saturday at 10 a.m i'm going to
upload the next chapter oh yeah and then
you can kind of comment and also
influence the story i guess because the
author is going to continually write it
yeah while reading comments and is this
what power stuff still going on is it
still oh wow it's alive and thriving i
need to check the website out it sounds
great
okay so you started with um a saucy
crossover fan fiction at the age of 14.
yeah and how
and then and now we've got the only the
only study
[Laughter]
yes um
okay so when i
i had the whole youtube success i guess
you could call it um in studytube i was
like okay cool wow people people are
clearly interested in this
and i know that i would have loved a
book like this that discussed not just
really good study tips of how to succeed
but also the more holistic elements of
being a student so all the perfectionism
fear of failure discussion that i loved
talking about on youtube
and i realized that in my gap year
naturally as my life would go on i
wouldn't be talking about this stuff all
the time so i really wanted an evergreen
medium where i could dig into it with
all the meat that you can't always get
into in a youtube video and it could
live on beyond me
um something where you know you don't
have to go and watch all these
bite-sized videos you can just
like everything i've ever said online
pretty much is in here animal yeah okay
so
you started with a fan fiction then you
decided you wanted to write the book how
did the sort of
how did the book actually end up
manifesting itself yes um so in my gap
year i started writing random passages
of this potential book idea i had in my
mind
but i never really committed to making
it an actual thing it was just an idea i
had i remember writing in my journal
like i'd love to write a book on this
but sort of you know i went to
university life takes over i have to
write all these essays too stressful i'm
not gonna write a book and then last
summer during lockdown i was approached
by a publisher and they were pitching a
book almost exactly like the one i'd
written down in my journal in my gap
year
and it just felt like
i don't know just felt like a
synchronicity
this this moment of if i don't write
this now i'm probably never going to
write it yeah and i know that i would
have wanted to read something like this
so
i said yes knowing that it was going to
be incredibly stressful to write this
during my university semester um because
the aim was to have it to be published
in august of this year so you got the so
you got it
basically 12 months ago ish the
publisher approached you yeah and you
just bashed it out in that time
that's pretty incredible because so for
a bit of context around the same time a
publisher approached me to write book
and i'm still
dabbling with the proposal and like it's
gonna be due to be released like two
years from now and i feel like such an
absolute waste man no we need to dig
into this tell me about your proposal
your fears about it because i feel like
the book for you i remember watching
your video where
you know you you sort of gave up on the
book yeah and it was exactly the time
that i was like crying over how much i
was struggling to write my own book and
i felt so validated in your video and i
honestly wanted to give that to
at that point but i could relate to
everything you were saying about you
know your fears of having an audience
and the expectations for it to be really
good and then your personal pressure of
wanting to be like a best seller yeah um
like it's a lot
you're becoming a bestseller now hasn't
it yeah i thought it was a title of your
yeah that's really cool it's really cool
and unexpected and i wasn't going for
that okay so it's it's kind of nice what
happens yeah
were you actually not going for that
were you like sort of semi-going for it
and like trying to convince yourself you
won't because that's sort of what i'm
doing
yeah i think at the start
yes yeah obviously who doesn't want a
bestseller and i think the beauty of
having a platform is you feel like it
could be within reach too yeah
um
but i think during the writing process
every time i had to sit down to write i
was just filled with so much dread
because every single word had to be a
best-selling word
and like every paragraph i'd read back
and be like but is this a best-selling
paragraph you know and i'm comparing it
to all these incredible books like
atomic habits or you know books that
have changed my life and thinking okay
but this is nowhere near that standard
um
so i think in order for me to finish it
i had to reshape my narrative around
okay what i wanted my book to be in
order to finish it and what did you
change that no
what was that narrative in the end okay
um
kind of how i do with perfectionism in
general
is firstly finish it
like don't overthink every single word
you're writing just get it down you can
edit it in the process
um but secondly
i think actually and maybe the first
time i heard this was you telling me was
there are no unique messages there are
only unique messengers and that's always
stuck with me
the fact that you know this doesn't have
to totally reinvent the wheel
it's already being reinvented through
the fact that it's coming through my
mouth i guess through my experiences
and
sort of finding value in whatever i have
to share and clearly there's something
valuable about it because i've been able
to build a platform off of talking about
these things so that was also this
confidence boost of being like jane you
have something to share it just doesn't
always feel like it's that valuable yeah
yeah yes and i i suppose when when
you're writing a book it's it's like
this is a book and a book feels like a
big deal yeah a youtube video doesn't
feel like a big deal although like
weirdly you know your youtube videos
will
will get more views then yeah almost
anyone will ever sell any copies of a
book so it's it's weird that like you
know you can get a million views on a
youtube video if you had a million
copies of a book you'd be like kind of
world famous like atomic habits
like changing um but there's something
about writing a book that just makes it
feel like a really big deal
um and i don't know if you have this but
like
i like like basically every week i need
to be told that my experience is
valuable what i have to say does have
does have worth because i always think
like why the hell would anyone give a
toss what i have to say about anything
yeah how did you kind of go about like
approach that
that side of it i feel like i still
struggle with that even the thought of
like
talking about the book and marketing the
book even though like i'm so proud of
this thing there's still a part of me
that doesn't like talking about the book
because i'm so scared that like it's not
good enough
okay like the imposter syndrome i don't
think it ever goes away
yeah because you're not an author you're
just a person right a person who's
written a book but that is what an
author is yes and that's how very much
how i feel i feel like i'm a person
who's written a book not an author um
yeah so i don't know i think just
support like having good people around
you like you said being told that your
work is good it's good like i um i have
an editor and i forced her to have a
call with me every week
and i forced her to like go through my
work with me and also just kind of like
validate that it was decent and i also
sent it out to like teachers and
students and got feedback from people
who
i guess said it was all right and then i
was like wow okay then i might as well
keep going i think that's helpful yeah
so there's a thing called london's
london writer salon which is like um
they have like in-person events but they
also have like four times a day writer's
hour which is like a zoom co-working
session
and so i joined this for the first time
like last week and there were like 300
people there and it was people from all
around the world joining in different
time zones and it was facilitated by
this person who's an author and they had
like five minutes at the start
where
is it free oh it's free yeah you just
joined it it's like a zoom call um oh it
was like a really good poem about
combating imposter syndrome as an author
share it with us
the problem is i can't remember where i
saved it this is the issue with having
like a zillion note-taking apps
um
where oh yeah it was this um this guy
called garth greenwell who's apparently
an author um and and in in this like
london writers group every every time
they do a session they share words of
wisdom to keep you going as a writer
so this is the quote um i remember
thinking as an mfa student that the
anxiety i felt would lessen when i got
an agent then when i sold a book then
when i got my edits then when the book
was published then when i got my first
review then when i got a particular
review then when i finished the second
book then when i saw the second book etc
at each point the content changes but
the anxiety remains the same
the only time the anxiety lessens is
when i'm bent over my notebook doing the
only work that matters trying to write a
decent sentence then another decent
sentence then one good page and another
i was like oh this is like really nice
like extremely relatable yeah for sure
we're going to take a very quick break
to introduce our sponsor for this
episode and that is brilliant i've been
using brilliant for the last two plus
years they're a fantastic platform for
learning maths science and computer
science with engaging and interactive
online courses and the great thing about
brilliant is that they really teach
stuff from a very first principles based
approach it's almost like the way that
we were taught in places like oxford and
cambridge where you learn a concept and
then you apply the concept to an
interesting problem rather than just
being spoon-fed stuff like we initially
learned in school my favorite courses on
brilliant are the computer science ones
as some of you guys might know i was
torn between applying to medicine and
computer science i went for medicine in
the end but i always had an affinity to
computer science and taking the courses
on brilliant like their introduction to
algorithms and their introduction to
python really helped me get more of a
grasp of computer science than i've ever
had before it's also great for learning
how to code which is an incredibly
useful skill to have especially if you
want to start a business and i attribute
like 98 of my business success to the
fact that i learned how to code when i
was in secondary school so if you want
to check out the courses on math science
and computer science then head over to
brilliant.org forward slash deep dive
and the first 200 people to sign up with
that link will get 20 off the annual
premium subscription so thank you
brilliant for sponsoring this episode
wait so where are you at so you have you
made multiple proposals but none of them
feel good enough i remember you writing
like a manuscript too yeah um so
we're on the third version of the
proposal and this now feels good
so it's taken 12 months to get to the
point where like finally the proposal
feels good and my agent and editor said
that sort of the soft deadline is the
end of this week um and so i'm going to
do a little sesh tonight doing chapter
outlines oh i've got a call with one of
my helpers tonight at 9 00 p.m doing
some more like chapter outline stuff
then we figure out the sample chapter
like the weird thing about a proposal as
you know is you've got to pretend like
you've written the thing before you've
actually written that you're like what
the hell yeah why it's useful yeah the
value of in the structure the whole arc
yeah it's crazy how how did you go about
structuring structuring yours
what was that what was the process yeah
i think what was helpful for me is i
already kind of had an idea of what i
wanted to do in my gap year
so i'd already written some passages and
sort of had these chapter outlines but
that was when i'd only done school so
now i sort of had this more life
experience from university and there
were things i wanted to add um so i
should have just blurted out everything
that i would want to include
um
and then sort of just found a structure
for me it wasn't actually too hard to
structure it okay yeah i think i'm over
thinking about quite a lot yeah don't
overthink it okay just write it and then
what were you were you like google talks
or notion like what was your motion
notion yeah and you can just like drag
bits around be like that exactly that
goes there that sounds reasonable
okay notebook and notion okay i think
i'm just overthinking this yeah i need
to have the perfect structure yeah
everyone keeps telling me it's like it's
just a proposal it can always change
okay i'm interested as well because i
thought you also have people involved in
your book right helping you out with it
do you think that adds pressure or do
you think it's helpful
i think it's helpful
um but
one thing i've realized over the last 12
months is that i can't lean too much on
other people because really like no one
knows what they're doing
we're all just making it up as we go
along and i kind of realized this that
i think i was hoping that
i'd be able to like hire someone who's
like worked on books before and just
like they would produce something
magical
um
and what it took me a year the last year
to realize is that and and something of
quite a few of them have said about
themselves is like like if we could
write a book we would be writing books
we would be helping authors write books
and so really it comes from the author
and they just kind of mold it into shape
um
and the other thing is that like that
thing of you that you said that you know
you've built an audience through sharing
you the stuff that's authentic to you
authentic to you yeah and so that should
probably be the stuff that's in the book
yeah rather than
thinking that someone else could like i
don't know mine your brain for all the
stuff and turn it into this magical like
life-changing thing yeah
um so it's really nice having people
helping to sort of sanity check me
and it's really like validating when i'm
i think yes i think i've got the perfect
structure and i share with someone
they're like oh this is really good
um i bet that feels amazing that feels
amazing it's like oh thank god i'm not
just in my head
um but yeah i think if i had if i if i
didn't have anyone helping with it and i
just
i just did it myself
i suspect i probably would have got to a
similar point sooner
um and just not like over thought
absolutely everything because there is a
point of like too many cooks potentially
spoiling the broth yeah sometimes
did you have that at all um so i
purposely like didn't get too many
people involved because
yeah i feel like with me i feel judged
if i'm sharing it all like all the ideas
with too many people because
sometimes i have to like have an idea
and then flesh it out and write it a bit
first before i want to share it so i
feel like if i was like i don't know
share an idea with someone in a zoom
call and then it was shot down straight
away i wouldn't even give it any life or
flesh that thing out that i thought
could be good um so yeah so for me it
was really helpful just having an editor
you know one person she's like deep in
my book understands me understands the
vision i talk with her once a week but
not like overdoing it with overthinking
but then that's just like me as a person
interesting so there this book i'm
reading called
i think it's called radical candor and
they talk it's it's it's sort of yeah a
sort of management business e-type book
um and they tell the the author tells a
lot of stories from her time working at
google and working at apple um and
around this idea of creativity and she's
she says that the mistake a lot of
people make is that they don't realize
that when something is just an idea it's
actually very very fragile and you don't
want to p anyone to shoot that idea down
while it's fragile you want them to help
build it up while it's fragile then once
it's built up at that point you want
people to start trying to poke holes in
it
um and that was like a real revelation
for me because i think i do the thing of
i i have a half-baked idea yeah and then
i share it with someone and they shoot
it down and i think okay well that's
stupid yeah and then you don't flush it
out it out but unlike like obviously a
half-baked tidy is very easy to shoot
down and i need to flesh it out or help
get people to help flesh it out before
then you know
presenting it to the world for it to be
shut down yeah if that makes sense
that's so interesting yeah do you feel
like you've learned a lot about yourself
through the process of trying to write
this book
yeah i do i'm curious
what have you learned about yourself and
then i'll i'll share mine so far
firstly i think i procrastinate so much
more
when i have like loads of expectations
about something you know i want this to
be good i want it to change people's
lives i wanted to be a bestseller all of
these unnecessary things
that i'm applying to something that you
know isn't even there yeah it hasn't
even been written
um yes and
uh secondly i
really need like a solid space like a
writing routine around a place
oh what does that look like for you like
for me um i had a cafe in seoul that i
when i went there i would never bring
other people
i
wouldn't like go on my phone like i had
complete sanctity of space over this
little cafe and i'd go there and i would
just sit for like three hours and write
and then leave and as soon as i stopped
writing i would leave and for me that
was like the most productive time of
writing the book at any point was when i
had developed that that place yeah
amazing i feel like that's what i'm
missing in my life right now because i'm
trying to do the writing kind of here
and there sometimes at home sometimes
like we work but it's always in the
middle of other things and i never have
like a clear three-hour block to just
write stuff
yeah i was gonna say because
like you i guess have many things on
your mind right you have youtube you
have like
other words
because like i was doing uni i had a uni
essay due all the time i had like two
essays a week sometimes the social life
for youtube everything that if i didn't
have the separation i don't think i
would have written anything what was
your like what was your routine like was
it like writing every day writing like
uh i couldn't write every day because
uni was just too much
i'd write like a few times a week but
based off of my schedule okay so
um i would block off in my calendar like
three hours to go to that cafe
um and i would just sit there and write
okay i'm gonna start doing this from
like today just blocking out time to
write
yeah i just haven't haven't really been
doing that um and it's like surprisingly
hard to make progress in like 20 minute
to half an hour segments here and there
for sure like you need that like
uninterrupted time to just think and get
stuff down actually like the first 20
minutes is like i just write crap
like you just sit there to write to get
yourself into the flow but the good
stuff doesn't come until like an hour in
yeah and then you have a really good
hour session of writing yeah after that
and did you find as well that like
writing stuff down helps you think stuff
through oh for sure
because i also find that i get off topic
in my mind if i'm not writing it down so
it's like okay cool i know i want to
talk about x like this thing in my head
so let me like think about it let me try
and develop it in my head it's not going
to happen if anything i'm going to start
overthinking something else or
yeah so definitely thinking through on
paper is the best and then you can read
back this horrible thing you've written
turn it into something good nice
so it sounds like so from from august
through to march you were sort of
chipping away at writing this thing
yeah what happens then in the book
publishing slash editing process
what does it look like oh my god it's
fascinating there's so many parts to
publishing i just didn't even know
existed um so
yeah so it went through my editor then
it went through a different editor then
went through a different editor and then
there's someone called a proofreader who
literally just goes and like checks for
grammar mistakes and what the editors do
is they just check for kind of grammar
mistakes too but just like we'll reword
sentences if they sound horrible
and the beauty of that process is it's
really collaborative so like
everything's like you know sent back to
me do you like how i've reworded this
sentence and i'm like no like let's
change that back um but they don't do
any major changes it's just like small
things and then after it's been sent
through a proofreader it gets typeset
which is fancy you know it's just
someone's whole job to put the words on
a page
um yeah so then all of the like
production side comes in
they do the illustrations i got to
collaborate with the designer on that
and then the cover was happening the
whole time while i was writing and how
did they pick how did you slash they
picked the title
oh the title the only study guide you
have yes this is this is probably the
most pretentious title of all time can
you tell i didn't pick it
um yeah i mean it kind of says what it
does on the tin like a bit of
pretentious added in
yeah i think just in
the world of studying
you need something that's like bam you
know just is obvious what what it is
um i came up with loads of you know
metaphorical names which were not half
as good like what i don't remember i had
this like notion pager just like brain
dump things but the publisher came up
with this and
i don't mind it how how did you feel
about the pretentiousness of it was it
like
of course are you kidding
um i think it's the same the same
imposter syndrome thing as if me little
of me has decided that i've written the
only study guide you will ever need ali
it's very pretentious but
i don't know i i think in the world with
sales and marketing it's all great
it's a very good title but it's weird i
think it was
who was i speaking to who i think sheen
mentioned to me that youth
maybe you mentioned one of the videos or
something that you thought this was
pretentious oh no when we were doing
research for this interview oh there was
a bit a bit where you said that this
title was pretentious and now like i
never once thought of it as a
pretentious title
until until i heard you mention it and i
was like oh okay oh yeah i can see
yeah and i imagine
this is so much of like
you know stuff is a bigger deal in our
heads than it is to anyone else and like
the only study guide you know yeah it's
so interesting like i'm not thinking at
all that like who the hell is jade
bowler to tell me is the only study
guard i'll ever need but that's probably
what's going on in your head
every time someone looks at this book
you know like who does she think she is
yeah no i had to have so many hype up
chats from friends about the title of
this book after it got approved
so let's let's talk about some of these
chapters um it's also like very
it's just a nice book
it's like
it's got like illustrations it's got
like
i don't know
i really like the design
it's like really pretty would i
illustrate like oh how did how did you
decide what you wanted the illustrations
to be and like
were you imagining it being like a
pretty looking book from the start or
more like an atomic habit-esque like
lots of text type work or what this is
definitely prettier than i thought it
would be definitely more text heavy
because
um it you know you have some beautifully
like illustrated um have you seen women
don't owe you pretty
great though yeah okay i feel like it's
become a trend in the book space to have
like instagramable books with you know
yeah this is very interesting oh thank
you but those are even more like
illustration heavy inside um so i wanted
to have an element of that that's
something you know you can just snap
some photos for instagram of the
diagrams and get something out of them
and also appeal to like visual learners
who might not have the time to read
everything controversial visual learners
i know true dude does that even exist is
everything that's true
um people who say that they are visual
and i wanted to have this put it in
practice section section as well so it's
like oh you know if i can't be bothered
to read the whole chapter i can just
skim through the summary of of the most
important points um i also wanted to
break it up by having contributions from
other people showing their experiences
um but yeah i knew it was gonna be text
heavy
so chapter one motivation yes
um what's the sort of the thesis of
what's your thesis about motivation
oh my god big questions actually
um okay so in this chapter i well the
first line i think captures it
when i got a d in my first a level
chemistry test i convinced myself that
it was bad luck and i sort of first dig
into
sort of failure and how that's really
unmotivational and then breaking down
what kept me trying after i had this
horrible experience with a teacher that
was just not good and
in my chemistry class it went from like
28 students to nine students the next
year because of you know issues with the
school and that was a point in my life
where i really felt like giving up on
this subject
and how i eventually found motivation
um i'm also conscious that you believe
motivation is a myth uh that's just a
title of a video but yeah i don't
actually motivations
so yeah i mean so yeah so i sort of dig
into this idea of what gets you
motivated is having a why of some kind
okay whether that is you know a
long-term goal of somewhere you want to
end up um you can have like an extrinsic
source of motivation which is something
like a grade you're trying to achieve or
university you're trying to get into
um but also trying to find this
intrinsic sense of why is it you're
studying like what is interesting about
these subjects even if you can't find
anything naturally
you need to convince yourself that
there's something interesting about this
like these maths problems are the basis
of
so many incredible things that maybe you
are interested in okay um and then
yeah using that motivation to then put
the systems into your life which i then
dig into for the rest of the book okay
so
so it sounds like
if if if something is like dull on the
surface you're saying that we can like
essentially talk ourselves into thinking
it's less dull yes and that gives sort
of the spark of motivation which then
once you build the systems then you can
stop relying on motivation like how how
does it work um kind of yes so i believe
that motivation is kind of just about
the narrative you tell yourself about
most things in life right the idea of
being demotivated is you not wanting to
do something and you don't want to do it
for a reason of what you're telling
yourself about that thing so if you're
you're not motivated to study why is
that do you not like the subject why
don't you like the subject i break it
down into things like conformity is it
because your peers around you don't like
that subject
is it the expectations people are
placing on you for example
you have a teacher who believes that
you're just not going to succeed and
you've told yourself that you are not
going to succeed in this subject um and
asking yourself these series of
questions that break down
why it is you're not trying and then
trying to find motivation through
reshaping that ah nice yeah that's some
good stuff
i say it's so much better in the book i
feel like i'm just rambling in this
yeah i guess the book has been through
like 18 levels of editing yeah all that
kind of stuff
say it in the same way but so we've got
chapter two the academic system chapter
three how we learn and i i noticed that
there was a cheeky forgetting curve
somewhere in there yes i think there's
also um i could be wrong but a little uh
contribution from
someone
yes uh i i was i was flicking through
this and i came i saw a forgetting curve
then i stumbled across my contribution
like a little bit a little bit later um
what is the forgetting curve for those
oh
i feel like everyone on your channel is
very familiar with the forgetting curve
okay so there's a guy called herman
ebbinghaus
he's a good friend of ours
um yeah and he basically did loads of
studies about human memory and found out
that you know when you when you're
learning something uh after a certain
period of time of not reviewing it your
memory decays exponentially
but if you review the same bit of
information at regularly increasing
intervals you can boost your attention
back up to that 100
which is why we have something called
space repetition which i feel like is
like i don't know as your brand half
your brand ali's face repetition
yes which is the idea that you review
information
at these regular intervals to combat
that forgetting curve
how do you personally recommend slash do
you personally organize your like space
repetition timetable like how do you how
do you do it okay so i use anki yep
which is like a flash card service that
effectively does it for you i always
also use quizlet um but i actually have
a spreadsheet
which is great um i also use it so i
have notion for like my timetabling of
my life i also have a spreadsheet for
all my different university chapters
and and then i use anki okay so do you
have stuff that is like not because anki
is very sort of like one bite at a time
type stuff
what about more like conceptual stuff or
broad picture stuff or you know
what is this person's theory about this
thing which would actually span like two
pages rather than one flash card yeah do
you
do you use space repetition for that
stuff as well how do you do it yes so i
combine it with other techniques i don't
know if you've heard of blurting this is
something i haven't watched oh this is
honestly my favorite technique
it's kind of active recall but i just
it's a technique called blurting where
you choose a chapter or a concept or a
process that you're trying to learn you
give yourself a few prompt words from
that chapter and then effectively you
just blurt out everything you can
remember from this process or topic or
chapter and then you you can set a timer
you can do how much you can do in five
minutes and then you compare it back to
your notes and then with a highlighter
fill in everything that you didn't know
or that you've forgotten and then you
compare that back and i think this is
something you also talk about which is
you know it's not about shoving
information into you it is about forcing
it out and that's how you learn and then
going back and noticing what you don't
know
um and so i use space repetition in how
often i blurt
nice yeah the whole like uh it's it's
it's so country intuitive in a way where
we just assume that the way we learn
stuff is by putting information in but
we actually learn stuff by taking
information out yeah that's weird mad
yeah and like completely contradicts the
whole like oh i'm just gonna sit and
highlight a textbook and read because
also it's strange because you feel the
most intelligent when you're reading the
textbook right yeah because all the
information is like i agree with that
that diagram is correct like yeah it
makes sense whereas you feel so stupid
when you're trying to drag information
from your brain and nothing's coming out
but that's you know when you're learning
the most actually learning yeah yeah
so we've got i imagine we've got all of
the whole active recall and
stuff in here um i was intrigued by
productivity hacks chapter six um this
is sort of up my street like
what would you say are the other key
productivity hacks that you found that
you found helpful yes
um so i kind of after having read so
many different productivity books yeah i
wanted to break it down to the most
simple that a student who
doesn't have time to read a thousand
things on productivity could just easily
implement and a lot of this is based off
of the pomodoro technique yep um i'm
sure you guys are familiar with this if
you're into the productivity space but
the idea that you know you set a timer
you choose one task focus on it for 25
minutes and then give yourself a break
um i think that's just an amazing one to
beat procrastination to be more
productive and also i actually i think i
quoted one of your your productivity
equations you have actually yeah i think
we've gone through this chapter and i
saw that off
but i think i also yeah i added
something you've like added stuff to it
yeah it's very interesting so so what's
your productivity equation okay so my
productivity equation is well maybe
we'll go back to the classic one yeah so
the classic productivity equation is
obviously output over time
so in a factory you know you're trying
to produce the most products in the
least amount of time or using the least
amount of resources
and what i added to this is if you
multiply it by focus and forethought
i think that is that's how you are the
most productive and then the whole
chapter is based off of around this
equation so the idea that if you can
reach this level of deep focus
whether that is having sanctity of space
like for me going to my cafe deciding
actively that i'm going to turn off my
phone and go into this place i'm going
to be far more productive
and the work is going to be more
meaningful um and then forethought is
the idea of planning you know having
your notion page your timetable um and
any planning that you do will make that
time much more productive and then
here's where i borrowed from you
fun because ali you know we've got to
make your life fun gotta make life fun
yeah
that's a really it's a very interesting
model so productivity equals output over
time multiplied by focus multiplied by
fourth thought multiplied by fun
three x three f that's really good yes
and then the chapter goes through like
focus for thought fun
a forethought feels a bit a bit
shoehorning into the three apps
but it's gonna be done it's memorable
yeah come on
yeah no i'm i'm i'm doing this all the
time in my book yeah it's like i've got
a word for it but it just i need like
three c's or three hours or three hours
or something it's a little bit yeah it's
just like but i'm gonna i'm gonna
remember the three apps now that's like
a really a really interesting way of
looking at it and i suppose once you've
got an equation you can then target
different bits of the equation exactly
yeah that's the thing you care about
um how do you feel about like toxic
productivity it's a word that gets
bandied about quite a lot um yeah yeah
no it's a really good thing um this is
what i talk about in i'd say the second
half of my book like all the stuff about
mental health um perfectionism hustle
culture all of that falls into toxic
productivity um i think it's people
misusing the idea of productive
productivity is spending your time well
yeah
i agree that's literally the definition
right
and that doesn't mean sitting and
revising for 10 hours which is what
productivity has often come to be
associated with and i think if you
reshape it to view productivity as just
spending your time well whether that's
it for enjoyment resetting self-care
then there almost isn't a toxic
productivity it's just you're not
spending your time in the best ways for
you um yeah and i think it is so
important for young people to
take more time for things like
mindfulness where you like totally
switch off from the internet and uh in
the chapters talking about exam season
um you know you're kind of like a
warrior going into a battle and when
when a warrior is like when a soldier is
going into battle they're thinking about
their diet their they're thinking about
the levels of rest they get you in a
good night's sleep before all of these
things and when you're in exam season
you start to do the same and one of the
most productive things you can do is
looking after yourself so
yeah i sometimes get messages from
people being like how how do i study
when i'm tired or how do you pull an
all-nighter i'm just like don't do it
don't fill in all that there's like
almost nothing to be gained uh from from
doing that stuff
what are your thoughts on toxic
productivity basically the same as yours
to be honest um i think the the way i i
usually so i often get accused of sort
of peddling toxic productivity stuff as
to a bunch of other i i i don't think
you do because you're very on the sort
of self self love type thing but if
you're of our other youtuber i used to
oh what did you do yeah okay
study tube yeah study tube 14 hour study
with me and like all that kind of stuff
and to me it's just a bit baffling
because
to me productivity is
doing the things that that matter to us
yeah and so to me hanging out with my
friends i i would consider productive
um and like playing russia and clank on
the playstation if i'm taking a break i
would consider productive yeah but i
think it's too easy it's very easy for
people to look at a headline 14 hours
tonight with me or something like that
not actually watch the video and realize
that it's actually four hours of work
and the rest of it is banter and part of
you know the advertising around this
video for it to do well on youtube has
to be something sometimes a little bit
extreme you know the only study guide
you ever need come on it doesn't mean i
think it's the only study right you'll
ever need yeah yeah there's a bit of
artistic license in the in the title
stuff um but yeah my theory i mean i
fully agree with your perspective on
this doing doing more of the things that
matter to us
uh whether that is taking a break
hanging out with friends hanging out
with family and doing things that are
meaningful to us so the forethought bit
and having fun along the way exactly and
like if you do more of that like i don't
know how that can be that can be toxic
but i guess it's it i don't know
yeah or even focus for me the idea of
that is when you're relaxing you
shouldn't be focusing on all the things
that you have to do and you know like oh
i should be revising right now like
focus on just watching that film or
enjoying time with your friends it's
like being present is productive
yeah no absolutely oh what
what do you
how would you define hustle culture you
mentioned that oh yes um
okay wow this is a this is a big topic
i feel like we have just been trained
our whole lives to value things with
output that's tangible
so you know whether that is a grade that
is the university that you're going to
the work you're going to get for a
paycheck like all of that has some kind
of goal you can work towards and so
anything like self-care where the thing
that you're achieving isn't tangible we
just don't value you know when when
that's looking after your mental health
it's not tangible output so you don't
put the same time and energy into it um
and that's so toxic we've got this
culture where it's like everyone wants a
side hustle which you know we love a
side hustle it's great but not at the
detriment of
killing yourself in the process because
that takes out the fun that takes out
the productivity all of it um
yeah
yeah this is something that like
i
often struggle with it's very much a
first world problem um where
i will feel guilty when i'm not doing
something that generates economic output
like
in the last few days i got the new
ratchet and clank game on the
playstation this is you know a game i
used to play a lot when i was like
between the ages of 8 and 13. and it's
been really nice just spending an hour
in the evenings just like shooting some
people with like this hot cartoon
thing but cool it's really good it's
like a very kind of childish game um
but i've historically been like
a sort of flip-flop between like
anti-video game and pro video game
anti-video game because it's a waste of
time that you know is not generating
economic output pro video game precisely
because it's a waste of time that
doesn't generate comic output this kind
of stuff
um and i feel like for me the more
successful i become in sort of output
terms the more the goal post changes and
i think oh but now we've got a team of
like 12 people and now you know you
could always do more right yeah i should
be doing more because now these people's
livelihoods are dependent on my youtube
channel being successful
how do you like
how do you kind of
find time slash make time for the
self-care stuff that's not associated
with economic output
i think in just the same way that you
plan your time for the things that
create economic output you have to plan
your time for the things that don't
at least that often helps me so like for
me i just have a really strong routine
in the morning
which sets my whole mind up for the day
like what does that look like oh it's on
jd jade's morning routine
yeah so i will do yoga meditation like
almost every morning without fail and i
find the days i don't do it i'm just a
worse human and that's not something
that's going to make me money or you
know it doesn't contribute to yeah doing
my job better even i guess it does um
yeah it's just something that makes me
feel good every morning i do that um
yeah and then also something i'm trying
to do is on sundays just not touch my
phone or you know try and like not be
in the social media world as much as i
am in the week
uh and then i feel like when i've when i
release this need to share
i i also don't i'm not in hustle culture
as much because i think being in the
study tube world or the productive world
you feel like you have to be
doing cool stuff so that you can share
the cool stuff and then when i've
decided well i'm not going to share
anything today then it's like half the
pressure's gone and then it's like only
myself i've got to do it for
and then i can just enjoy my time a bit
more
interesting what is your what does your
yoga yoga and meditation practice look
like yeah um i do youtube using videos i
don't know if you know yoga with age oh
yes you do they started her 30 day
challenge and got to about day seven
what happened ah i forgot to do it one
day and then
yeah i intended to do it at some point
and never never really come around to it
you know that the
classic yeah i really like her i also
really like um yoga with patrick patrick
and carling he's like tough power yoga
okay which i really like so i do like a
bit of hers like soft yoga good for
breathing yeah very wholesome you just
feel safe in her presence like she's
lovely yeah
and then he's a bit more like okay i'm
sweating
so that's that's like a nice balance to
me and then i always do like a five
minute meditation on insight timer or
youtube
oh okay
nice so you just like wake up and decide
to put on a random youtube video or do
you have like a playlist that you're
working through yeah again it depends so
sometimes i like put it ready on my
youtube the night before just like
reduce the friction in the morning when
i'm tired i can just wake up and do it
okay yeah just like roll out of bed on
two yoga mat and then do start like yeah
oh like generally
yeah play now remember last time we
spoke um
that inspired me to get a yoga mat oh i
now have a yoga mat um which is like
behind that curtain over there
and i was using that for like home
workouts and like yoga sessions during
lockdown when that was a thing um how's
your yoga habit now it's entirely
non-existent right now
but i'm moving to london in about seven
days time so i'm i mean that's exciting
hot yoga i really want to try it so good
i love it yeah i've heard good things
have you ever tried acro yoga never but
i also really wanted to try that yeah
that would be absolutely sick yeah um do
you follow sam caulder and chelsea
kawaii and stuff on instagram
they're really cool these like travel
vloggers instagram people sort of they
do these incredible like acro yoga
routines
so cool both like in incredible shape
he's got like six pack abs like all the
time it's like absolute goals
and every time i see one of their videos
i'm like whoa this looks awesome uh it
looks really hard though um no that's
definitely a goal in my life to try that
nice yeah yeah i'm gonna try and do a
few classes in london once i i i feel
like i'm deferring a lot of things to
once i move to london then i will do x
so easy to do
i feel like it's too easy to do that for
a lot of things in life as well that's
so cheap once i finish uni then i'll
start a yeah
you know once once i get promoted then
i'll be happy why not today why not
today exactly i should just do it today
do you have any things that you feel
connect your mind and body what does
that mean that's a deep question i know
so for me i find yoga is a practice that
really just makes me feel more like
present so my mind is like switched off
i'm in my body and then for the whole
rest of the day i just feel like more
grounded more connected i know what you
mean i have this on friday mornings when
i have my tennis lesson at eight o'clock
oh wow there you go i i yeah that's
that's the feeling i always feel like
really good after that lesson and then i
like sort of ready to crush it the rest
of the day it's really cool um
huh i should do more activity in the
morning but yeah that would be a fun
thing because it just sets up your whole
day to be better yeah and we've got like
these balls flying at you from a coach
you can hit them really hard it's like
yeah time to think you just haven't have
you always done tennis no
i dabbled with it in school but i
started taking it seriously about six
months ago
and i realized that you can just like
get lessons and stuff yeah and it's
great and here we come home here we come
at some point it's a it's on the bucket
list um
so
so
meditation as well i i i've been
dabbling um i'm on day four of sam
harris's waking up app oh yeah i've been
on day four for about a week now so what
does the app have you do
it's just a very beginner 30-day course
for now okay just like sit in a quiet
place and then you have it in your
airports or whatever yeah and it's
mostly like breathing and
he just like occasionally is like okay
at this point you probably find your
mind is wandering so
don't worry i was gonna say how do you
find it do you find you're like able to
generally focus on the guided meditation
or your thoughts everywhere i find i'm
usually able to focus on it i just i
feel like i haven't done it for long
enough to actually get the benefits of
it because i do it for a day or two once
i speak to someone like you yeah it's
like meditation yes
and then something or the other happens
and i have like a zoom call at 8am and
i'm like oh god yeah i don't know and
then i think what the hell am i doing i
can literally do whatever i want i
choose my own schedule this was the
point of all of this like yeah i don't
know side hustle stuff yeah and yet the
calendar still feels outside of my
control so
i need to i need to sort this out yeah
that's not good wait why aren't you
saying recently that like your calendar
feels like it's taken up by a lot of
managing people and yeah as opposed to
just doing activities for you or like
general strategy i guess for you as a
person yeah how has that been this shift
of managing people it
is really fun
and i used to think that meetings were a
waste of time and i used to look at
people's calendars who have like meeting
after meeting after meeting and think
like how can you possibly get anything
done
um but now that i've got a fairly big
team
it's like my time is actually best spent
in a meeting
kind of sharing some ideas and a vision
and basically telling other people what
to do
which feels really good
but then if i take a step back i'm like
i've just been in meetings like
literally from nine o'clock to five five
p.m and i've got like a three hour long
podcast and i've got like another zoom
call with my writing coach and now it's
like 11 p.m
like it's like when you're in it you
don't realize just how like
all-encompassing how all uh soul-sucking
it can be
and then occasionally when i find time
to take a step back i think what the
hell is going on with my calendar um but
i'm finding that given that i live my
life by my calendar i've now blocked out
four hours wednesday afternoons called
uh at least time to think that like no
one can interrupt anything yeah and i
will try not to bring my phone into that
yeah to just like write or just yeah and
go for a walk or things like that
um the other thing i'm trying to do is
scheduling something in at like
five or six p.m for an hour like an
activity or something which forces me to
get out of the office or get off my
computer yeah and then that's like a
reset yeah and you're probably more
effective up until then right because
you're like i need to get it all done by
this point exactly
and then in the evening if i really want
to and i'm really enjoying it then i can
choose to do more work yeah things that
look like work yeah um but if not then i
can just play playstation or hang out
with a friend or amazing so that's
that's a theory anyway i'm gonna
implementing it over the next few weeks
and i'll report back and let you know
how it goes i was gonna say wow that's
so cool though this shift to i guess
managing the whole company right like i
know i heard you saying that you were
reading a lot more books in the business
space has that been helping you a lot oh
yeah yeah i feel like every time i read
a new business book i'm like damn i wish
i'd discovered this sooner
um because again like a few years ago i
would have been like oh business books
what a waste of time
you learn business by doing business oh
actually
these guys these guys have like 40 years
of experience running like they know
what they're talking about this is some
good advice um so now i'm finding that
something i'm interested in is your idea
of hierarchy in your business
do you feel like a superior to the
people you're working with a lot of the
time is it like does it feel like you're
almost friends and then you're bouncing
ideas off of each other like how do you
think about it and i don't know if
you've heard of like holacracy or more
oh no what's that oh we can talk about
that after okay
um okay how do i feel about hierarchy i
don't feel like a superior in any way
um in fact and i i very much see us all
as
you know we're all friends we're on the
same team kind of thing
but at the same time
there is that thing of i have i
i know i need to communicate like an
expectation of what like what i want and
what success looks like
and i often do a very bad job of doing
that because i think oh we're just
friends we're all just making up as we
go along and it's only recently that i
realized like if i set like a goal like
an arbitrary goal of like you know by
the end of the year we want 150 000
subscribers on the email list
like that's actually quite useful yeah
for jakub who's our marketing guy who's
helping grow the email list because now
he's got something to shoot for exactly
yeah whereas before i was like okay is a
waste of time yeah who cares about kpis
um i i'm also surprised as to
because in my head i'm just making it
all up as i go along and so when i like
float an idea by the team
in my head it's just an idea and it's
just a rough pencil sketch
uh but in their heads it's like oh ali
said we need to do something so we need
to do the thing
and then like a week later it's like the
idea changes and then people are like oh
but you said this other thing last week
like now you're changing your mind every
other day like what's going on i'm like
wow
yeah weird because i didn't i didn't
think i asked you to do anything but
they took my rough idea pressure
okay cool so i realized i've had to kind
of
to me over communicate a lot where and
where it's like okay guys just to
clarify i don't know what i'm talking
about you don't need to action this you
don't do anything right now i'm just
floating an idea
don't do anything with it all that kind
of stuff um this has been some of the
challenges with the management stuff but
it's like really fun yeah and it's
really fun like working with people and
like so cool angus is over here at the
moment
just hanging out uh
it's been really really nice having
people in wework co-working space
um to the point where all of the people
we're now hiring we want to be based in
london and to have like an actual london
office um and your agency 16 has been
like danny and fran and stuff have been
really helping us on the operations side
about like what it's like to grow a
business and things like that
so that's been fun wow cool what about
you have you thought about like kind of
expanding teamifying your yeah
not right now just because i think while
i'm in university
my priority is still
having a social life and learning about
myself and just making mistakes and just
just living my life as a person beyond
youtube because i feel like that's
that's so important to me during
university and i'm also lucky i get to
travel a lot do all these things um and
i think i don't have the freedom to do
that when i'm investing so heavily in
youtube so the next two years of my life
is still in that experiment phase and
then i think after youtube when i'm like
okay cool like maybe this is the career
that i want to pursue that i'll turn it
into something but right now i i like
the flexibility of my life are you not
worried that
and i i so the
this is my thought process with this
that like
i have hit the jackpot my i got i right
place right time youtube channel took
off i really don't want to screw this up
the algorithm anything could happen to
my channel anything could happen to
algorithm if i stop uploading videos at
the cadence of two videos per week
something bad is going to happen and i
don't want that something bad to happen
from experience
and therefore giving your chained to the
algorithm exactly yeah
yeah
it seems like you have like shared the
chains of the algorithm i think at least
that's what it looks like on the outside
i have yeah how do you do it
defining your priorities in life okay if
your priorities are just numerical
success for your whole life then
brilliant
but for me i know that my human
fulfillment does not just come from
youtube and yes when i'm succeeding it's
brilliant i feel great you know like
it's just this is like i don't know how
to describe it it's like this thing in
the background like i know it's all
going good you know with the algorithm
um
but in the times of my life where i've
only focused on youtube and i've been
doing the best with the algorithm
sometimes when i'm the least happy
because i'm not putting the same energy
into relationships in my life into
i don't know just learning about myself
through other activities
so i define that as a priority for
myself is while i'm at university i want
to have the space to
not just be a youtuber and to be messy
and you know an element of like being a
bit chaotic at uni means
i can't do you do youtube to the same
extent as if i was just focusing on it
um okay yeah so reprioritization okay
but it's a sacrifice for sure
so then do you think at all about like
two years from now
if you don't take youtube so seriously
that maybe
the youtube career won't be there and
you'll have to like get a real job is is
that something that concerns you
in it used to but no oh okay no because
the algorithm okay yeah if you don't
post for a bit it might come back and
have to build things up again but
if you're able to do it once why can't
you do it again you know
like you've clearly learned how to do
this you have something of value to
share people want to listen to you
people know who you are
and even if it took six months of you
you know working hard to get back to
anywhere close to where you were
you've done it before it'd be so much
easier than the first time around and
yet you would have gained so much in the
time off it's how i view how you i'm not
saying you have to quit youtube but i
also do i feel this fear in you ally to
like
to
to stop you know when you when oh yeah
the algorithm's so on your side i'm so
proud of you like you do so well on
youtube um but i remember when we were
having the chat last year about you
thinking about traveling and
increasing your surface area for
serendipity all that stuff all that
stuff yeah and i can imagine it must
feel even further away when it's like
you know you've got a team and you're
learning all this stuff on this
incredible business side um
but yeah i don't know is there still a
part of you that thinks there's the
things you want to do beyond youtube but
you're chained by youtube
yeah i think so i think the way that i
think of it is less about youtube
specifically and more about like the
wider
kind of being a thought leader you know
that sort of
internet personality kind of thing which
sounds really cringe to stay out loud um
he's a thought leader
that's a dream anyway um
and the thing that always
worries me is that
it's all
as as much as we've tried to diversify
away from youtube it's still all very
dependent on youtube for sure and i look
at
you know there are very few youtubers
who were big 10 years ago who are still
big today um tech youtubers have done
well in like staying relevant and things
and so
i i often think about this as like
what exactly am i am i scared of because
you know the business is doing well
we're sufficiently profitable etc but
i'm still like climbing climbing the
greasy pole of like subscriber count and
like views and like revenue and all this
sort of stuff and there's gonna be a
point at which it has to stop slash like
take a step back
so that's one side of me but the other
side is like yeah but it's really fun
and yeah we're getting an office we're
hiring a team and it's like cool and
i actually if i think about what i would
find more fun i think being in london
and going to a we work every day feels
to me more fun than like traveling would
for now yeah and so i feel like in this
season of my life which is kind of like
a hustle kind of season
while on the same you're doing acro yoga
and playing playstation and stuff on the
side to you know self-care um it feels
like
why not do the hustle thing for as long
as it's fun and if it stops being fun
then i'll i'll reassess yeah so i don't
know
that's really valid too
yeah
yeah and like as you say you know you've
got this whole new chapter ahead of you
in london with a team in an office like
that's a that's an adventure in itself
that's a huge change i thought you've
you've engineered your routine here so
that's going to be a huge change yeah i
feel like it hopefully should be fun um
so you're having a big change in a
couple of weeks right you're going to
bully yes i am although i've lived there
before i've studied that before which is
amazing because it's the first time in
my degree that i'm going back to a city
so i feel like i already have you know
some of my favorite places there
yeah it's just very exciting how long
were you there for last time four months
okay two of which were in total lockdown
okay so really two months yeah two
months and then this time around how
long is it for uh four months ago okay
four and a half months yeah what's that
like kind of being in a city for like
four months four months at a time i've
i've never really done that
oh okay uh it's it's so many things it's
a lot of emotions right um it's
incredible you find uh like my concept
of home has shifted a lot because you
you do find a home in this place like i
know i leave a piece of my heart
wherever i go i swear like all these
cities around the world um
yeah and i i don't know i've kind of
developed this routine of first month is
going to be really tough
everything is new the language the
culture the people
all of it is just like totally out of
your comfort zone second month things
get a little bit easier you're
developing a routine and then third
month is just sweet spot like every life
is just amazing you've found like it's
like honeymoon you know you've got your
routines you understand this place and
then fourth month
is still good but like i'm learning to
leave and leave it behind so it's like
bittersweet um
yes so it's it's good but then i also
sometimes feel this lack of stability in
moving a lot okay because it's you know
i get to experience these amazing places
but then i know it's always going to be
for a short time okay
is that
because of the university thing keeping
you moving okay
do you think you'd well once you
graduate you'd want to continue the sort
of traveling living in a new place every
four to six months sort of lifestyle
or has it gone out of your system so
like
yeah yeah good question um i don't know
if i'm honest i think part of me wants
stability and like friends in one place
yeah um but at the same time
it's so amazing like the whole slow
travel thing where you live in a new
place um you just learn so much about
yourself really quickly like every place
you go is so different
and like force is a different version of
yourself i feel what do you mean you
learn about yourself
okay um
so for example berlin and seoul i think
two of the most different places you
could be in like berlin is like
i don't know so individualistic like as
in like you're you're in the street
people don't care what they wear and i
love it you know people could just be
like wearing a bin bag or wearing a suit
and everyone will look at you exactly
the same people play their music super
loud and
and that's just them living their life
and people will you know sometimes just
like dance in the street to the music
everything's just very free
um whereas in seoul
it you know it's very respectful culture
you have to be a lot kind of quieter and
sort of keep to yourself yeah this sort
of collectivistic thing and i never
lived in in a place i like either of
those two
um so in berlin it sort of
taught me i could i could you know take
up more space and experiment with my
fashion and
um yeah like that was a side of myself i
got to explore whereas when i went to
korea
you know you're on the bus and if you
talk people will look at you until you
stop talking
so it's like wow i learned that you know
i'm a lot louder than i always thought i
was or that i enjoy conversations with
strangers which will never happen here
because everyone will keep kind of keep
to themselves more because of the
language differences um so yeah so you
come out of the places having learned
about how you would adapt to these
situations and what aspects of your
personality you
you like to express oh and do you think
there's like a
minimum effective dose in terms of like
length of time that you're in a place
because i've been to japan for a week at
a time i don't think i learned anything
about myself in that time um but like
yeah
for sure i think you have to like live
there yeah like commit to living there
not just like a holiday
i don't know if there's a minimum amount
of time i think three months you could
probably do it but i think four months
really has been like a sweet spot for
living in a city kind of as i said those
phases that you go through in the months
i think two months is really just the
the exposure thing and figuring
everything out and then that third month
is when you're you're feeling a bit okay
so a few minutes ago we were talking
about the youtube channel and you said
that you're
wondering whether youtube is going to be
your career two years from now when you
graduate
how do you think about this this concept
of like career and this thing of like
because because
my my view on this is that like
what does career even mean it's like uh
like if you're if you're a doctor that's
a career if you're a lawyer it's a
career because it's like oh there's one
thing that you're doing kind of there's
a clear progression
but i feel like for you and for me maybe
like the word career doesn't feel quite
quite right
how are you thinking about that kind of
concept that's so true yeah career is
definitely like an old old-time phrase i
think where the assumption is you know
you go to one company and you stay there
for your lifetime and work up the
hierarchy
but no i feel like people have multiple
careers in their life that is the new
definition of a career um
yeah i think
just doing whatever feels right at that
time job-wise is probably the best thing
you know i have friends right now who
are graduating and going into random
jobs that that's not going to be their
long term career but no doubt they're
going to go there they're going to learn
a lot they're going to learn what they
do they don't like they're going to meet
people who are going to lead them on to
other things and i think that is what we
should normalize as a career is just
just doing things and you know throwing
what's the expression throwing something
at a wall oh yeah throwing spaghetti at
the wall throwing spaghetti at a wall
yeah and just if you don't like the
career you change and youtube is a is i
guess a phase of our overall careers
which will lead us onto
other things yeah
yeah that's a good point
yeah i find that
so
my mom is fairly old school in her like
approach to stuff
i think like a lot of a lot of parents
are um
and her whole thing is that like you
know
that for me that i should have a plan
and the fact that i changed my mind
every you know every every few months
from what i want to do is like signs
that i'm scatterbrained and you know
don't have any clear like whatever
whatever
um
and
it's like
when i have conversations with her it's
like a part of me wonders should i have
more of a plan like a clearer idea of
where i want to be five years from now
should i do an odyssey plan and actually
stick to it or
um well then the other half is like well
you know i'll just i'll just do what's
fun in the moment and what seems to
roughly make sense and things will work
out
so relatable
yeah i i think there are some things you
need a plan for like if you decide you
want to be a doctor that's something
you've got to plan for and and from now
to there is like a very clear trajectory
um but yeah i know recently i was making
like a mood board for my life like a
vision board oh okay and this is really
hard because i don't know what i want to
do with my life yeah and i don't know
where i want to live like all of these
things are very hazy but i still wanted
to try and create like a vision board of
some kind and scrolling through
pinterest trying to be like okay like
what resonates with me i don't even know
what to type in um and i think i was
just trying to capture more of a feeling
or a set of values
that are kind of timeless in in what i
want to okay how i want to shape my life
and the mood board is still in progress
but
um like right now i love the flexibility
i have in the fact that my job can be
remote you know like you can do youtube
from anywhere that's something i really
value i've been able to do at university
um i love the flexibility to sort of
make a video on whatever i want to
and realizing those things about what i
like now is probably going to be quite
similar in five years and what i want
from a career so i find that useful but
so what is a vision board
oh it's just like a collection of
images
phrases words like you can do magazine
clippings but like digitally use
pinterest yeah
um yeah and the idea is that you put it
up and when you look at it
it gives you the feeling of the
direction you want to go in it's like a
kind of like a source of motivation but
also like a hazy direction in pictures
because you've talked in a few videos
about like manifestation and stuff like
what
or what is the so
i've read the secrets uh i haven't read
the scene okay cool
and everyone everyone i've i've heard
everyone i've heard speak about the
secret does it in very like disparaging
terms like well there's also
manifestations of it it's all like bs um
but you like talk about it sincerely
yeah or it seems to be like what is
manifestation to you and how does it
manifest in your life
as it were um okay so to me it's kind of
common sense okay
in in a way if you want something
you're gonna have to say it out loud
you're going to have to take actions
towards it and you're also going to
probably need a bit of luck because
that's how life works
and that's kind of common sense you know
like if you want a certain job if you
want to be a doctor you first got to
decide that's something you really want
you've got to be very specific say okay
i probably in the next five years i'm
going to have to apply for med school
i'm probably going to want to go to
maybe this university then you can say
it out loud you can write it down it
becomes kind of a clearer thought um and
then you have to use wait let me say
that again
just through yeah like putting it down
on paper you're already thinking about
actions of how you're going to go
towards that whether it's like working
harder for certain grades and then the
element of luck
that i guess the law of attraction comes
into
you know you can call it synchronicity
you can call it luck you can call it the
universe you call it whatever you want
to but there's always an element of that
okay um so the law of attraction is that
to me it's you decide something and you
get really clear on what it is you want
and then you can also assist that thing
with visualizations like the more you
can picture yourself
having that thing the more likely you
are to have it just because you're going
to shape your actions towards also
getting it
so what would the the visualization
thing look like yeah
um so i think this falls into realm of
meditation for example like closing your
eyes i i think about this with an exam
like the night before an exam if you
close your eyes and you picture yourself
from the exam hall most people
first thing you think of is stress you
know you're like flicking through the
paper you've got no time and you're kind
of manifesting that version of you being
stressed without you doing anything
about it
so in order for you to do the opposite
you'd have to visualize yourself being
there being calm being rational being
focused and like you know feeling quite
confident kind of fake it till you make
it and the more that you picture that
imagine yourself in it yeah then the
more likely you are to borrow from that
visualization and naturally do it so
yeah it's kind of just imagining the
best case scenario but that makes you
more likely to also do that scenario
okay does that make sense
yeah it does um
i feel like i sometimes accidentally do
this without realizing i'm doing this
um
there was this guided meditation thing i
did the other day
uh
which was
sort of about imagining your life some
years in the future what does your house
look like what's the family look like
what are you spending your time doing
and before doing it i was like oh this
is going to be some stupid meditation
thing yeah and then
and and then i did it it was like 20
minutes and i was like oh wow i've just
never spent any time thinking what could
my life look like in the future and i
had like a very specific
sort of
vision of what like my future house
might look like and you know i was like
oh you know
in this in this vision like you know the
wife is tucking the two kids into bed
there's like a third one on the way
we've got a little fireplace i've got
like my little desk in the corner that
has like an imac on it or whatever it's
like a guitar i've been playing the
guitar it's like a dog and it's like oh
this is kind of nice and since doing
that like last week
i have been thinking back to that and
thinking oh i wonder what sort of dog i
want like it's just like
just random
i very rarely think what sort of dog do
i want in the future but the fact that i
had that i did that visualization thing
is now like a thing where i feel like oh
yeah i'm definitely going to get a dog
in the future
that's so cool um
and so
i don't know i feel like i want to do
more in the way of like this sort of
vision boarding e type stuff
that's awesome
yeah that's basically what the law of
attraction is or at least the way i
think about it it's just getting clear
on your vision for your life which we
don't do enough
and i don't i'm not clear on that but as
soon as you know you start to have an
idea it does sort of work its way into
your mind more and then you're more
likely to make it happen would you be
open to sharing some of the things in
your vision board
or is it like a private thing
it's kind of private because i don't
know like if this is actually what i
want okay no fair enough
um have you found the manifesting stuff
helping another aspect of life as well
um
like in yeah i think in terms of
confidence oh okay was it like you
imagine yourself as being more confident
exactly you are more confident yeah that
makes a lot of sense yeah right like
again that's how you get until you make
it yeah
okay or even for example with the book
like when i was writing this book when i
had to go down and sit down and you know
it was dreading the writing process
visualizing myself as someone who had
written the book who had finished it
and was receiving a nice review from
someone about how it helped them but not
in like a stressful way just like oh you
know that was this was clearly helpful
to them things like that you know it
just it helps you then find that
motivation to sit down and write okay
that's very interesting
and do you do do you do this like
actively do you have like a slot in your
calendar for like manifesting time or
like how does it work within your life
because i have a sort of routine of
meditation
some of those meditations i choose to do
on that day could be in the realm of
manifestation okay you type in
manifestation meditation on youtube and
someone will give you a guided tour
exactly oh okay yeah so i guess that
that must have been that thing that i
did the other day which is just like
someone talking about like
close your eyes imagine yourself five
years from now yeah think about the
sounds think about the feelings that
kind of stuff and you can just imagine
if you did that meditation every day
like every day you sort of add to that
vision yeah definitely you're like oh i
have a dog and like oh i'm starting to
see like a poodle you know like would i
like a poodle the next day you do the
meditation you're like actually no it's
a golden retriever yeah
okay
that's interesting because i guess in my
head meditation is like you sit there
doing nothing for
example i think most people think that
yeah there's so many different types
like visualizations meditations there
are like breathing frameworks um just
being present and you know hearing
everything around you engaging with your
senses there's loads and you don't need
to i guess again when it comes to
meditation i think i overthink it and
like uh i need to find the perfect like
puff whereas it sounds like we're eating
just like type in some random meditation
on youtube depending on what you're
feeling and just go for it exactly and
that's like obviously good for you yeah
and because i know that the practice of
meditation generally is good it doesn't
really matter what it is like just
closing my eyes and like forcing myself
to breathe for like five to ten minutes
i'm showing up like i'm doing the work
you know it doesn't need to be like a
perfect meditation every day and if i
like it can do it again sick
that is very cool i'm gonna turn to our
instagram audience now with some
potentially rapid fiery type questions
okay um
the questions are going to be rapid but
the answers don't necessarily have to be
i'd love to expand on stuff if you like
uh oh wonderful we have we have
categories as well what is hashtag
casual magic oh
okay so casual magic is a concept that
i've been practicing for the last few
years the idea is that not every day is
gonna be your wedding day or your
anniversary your birthday or like an
objectively exciting day
but that means that like i don't know
the rest of your life that like 99.9 of
your life is just boring or you don't
frame it in a way that has that much
meaning or gives you that much happiness
so the idea of casual magic is every day
finding something really casual in your
mundane life that you find magic in so
for example the way that the light's
coming into the room is really beautiful
or i don't know just like having a nice
tea and just like actively noticing to
yourself like this is a nice moment like
it's really casual but a little bit
magic
and
like after reading so many books on
happiness yeah that's sort of one of the
things i found is it's all about how you
personally find meaning so trying to
find meaning every day
what's your casual magic today
my casual magic today um
something little that you're grateful
for something little that i'm grateful
for
i really like these bulbs we we put
these like
these like little fairy light type
things up yesterday because we were
having a goodbye leaving party for sheen
and i think it's just a great vibe yeah
i had a good vibe to the room so i'm
gonna keep them love it
um
yeah i think like i i had a few friends
whose bedrooms had that sort of like
lighting type stuff in them i always
just think oh this is really cozy and
nice i just never thought that like
it was part of your thing yeah but now i
think it'll be part of the aesthetic i
love it what advice would you give ali
about writing a book
oh
apart from all the stuff already yeah
i love chat about that um stop
overthinking it firstly
um
flesh out those ideas before sharing
them with other people like sit with
yourself and write them and thirdly
find
your space your like sanctity of space
around a moment a place a cafe something
like that that's just yours don't bring
any of your writing people there okay
right yeah sanctity of space that's a
nice phrase is that one that you've
invented
yes nice that's good that's a good way
of framing it
um adash says how did you name the
chapters of your book
oh good question um i don't know i just
i thought about it and then yeah and did
it fairly like quite basically
how we learn
study methods yeah it's time for
timetables oh nice thanks that's good
probably the best one
mental health and i before an exam ready
for battle if you're ready for battle i
could have one dramatic it's gonna be
done yeah i mean like the title plus
that challenge
um uh anjara says what's your favorite
book
yeah the only study kind of link in the
video description
uh oh
i think atomic habits has really shaped
my life in a positive way
or the four-hour work week was one of
the first business-y books i ever read
um oh yeah one concept that really stuck
with me was the idea of the mini
retirement in four-hour work week um
yeah i say the four-hour work week has
just been really what what's the mini
retirement thing for the
unfamiliar oh yeah um so it's the idea
that you know generally we wait till
retirement to enjoy our lives or do all
these things like go traveling um and
tim ferriss he has a mini retirement
every year where you know you can take
like a month and do
exciting things you can go traveling
rather than waiting your whole life to
finish your work you can like work your
whole life and have the retirements in
between
yeah we're we're trying to sort of do
this concept within our team whereby uh
every six or seven weeks we have we all
take a sabbatical for a week uh where
like nowhere gets done it's also
published like one video which has been
pre-scheduled and stuff yeah uh and no
one's allowed to do any work uh they
kind of they really really want to but
it's like you know encouraging people to
take a break do you actually not do work
during that time so far we've done it
for one week whereby it was basically
100 work from mine and angus's part i
feel like some of the rest of the team
took actually took some time off okay um
but one of my one of my friends
has been doing the sabbatical thing for
the last like seven years he says it it
takes you a few rounds to actually get
into the habit of not doing any work for
a week yeah but i'm hoping it'll happen
at some point
um okay studymed says what did you like
and dislike most about your book writing
journey oh uh like the most
is when i read back like a paragraph or
something i just had this feeling of
this is good like that doesn't happen
often you know well you're like this is
actually something of value or when
you're really overthinking how you want
to say something or um like for example
mental health i talk about in the book
and i came up with this metaphor about
how mental health is like the weather
and when i hit that i was like oh this
makes so much sense to me and i think
this could really help people why is
mental health like the weather oh okay
so
if you think in the uk every day you
wake up and the weather's different you
don't know how it's going to be
sometimes it's good sometimes it's bad
but either way sort of got to get on
with your day the weather doesn't define
the day it doesn't define how you are
even though it can change how it is but
you know it's a universally recognized
thing that we have weather and it's
going to change and mental health and
from that perspective is the same like
every day your mind is going to be a bit
different you're going to have days
where
you know you're feeling under the
weather oh
yeah and it doesn't define you it's just
you know your mind that day might be
feeling a bit worse and you just have to
observe it and you know if it's raining
outside you pack an umbrella but often
if you're not feeling good one day you
don't do anything for it you know you
don't like
you don't do a meditation or take time
for yourself like you might do to
protect yourself from the weather
yeah and then one thing i kind of went
on to talk about is in the uk we talk
about the weather a lot yeah but we
never talk about mental health and so
it's this paradox you know why can't we
turn mental health into something that's
talked about and checked on just like
the weather is how do you notice how
you're feeling
yeah so this is something i talk about
in the book is developing a practice of
some kind which is you checking in so
that could be journaling
which can be can feel like a lot of
friction at the start but it's an
amazing habit to get into it's like
brain dumping how you feel or just
thoughts in your head and as you write
like stream of consciousness and you
read it back you can often get a gist of
how you're feeling especially when you
compare it um or meditation even just
closing your eyes for one minute and
just stopping all the distractions
that's checking in for me
how are you feeling right now yeah this
is a good question
how am i feeling right now um
can i just say
this is something i've been realizing
this year yeah
boys and men oh my god they i feel like
they dread the question how are you
feeling right now no one can answer it
why can't you answer it
okay
so the reason i can't answer it it's
because so i've been thinking about this
this genre of stuff a lot over the last
few weeks to months
i think
i never take the time to think about how
i'm feeling
and therefore when asked how are you
feeling like literally the only work of
the word that comes to mind is good yeah
that's so unsatisfying
but
apparently the the thing that you do is
get into the in the habit of not using
those words and like elaborating more on
what it feels like
and i just don't do that and therefore
it just feels it feels unnatural and
weird and like i'm sort of making stuff
up
um
how are you feeling around that like how
how would you describe your
yeah um okay um
i think a little bit self-conscious if
i'm honest
because i'm like aware that there's
loads of cameras and anything i can say
is gonna be used like probably and i'm
gonna stumble and i'm not in control of
the editing process so
like yeah a little bit subconscious but
at the same time relaxed like it's a
nice environment here
okay
that's reasonable
that's better than that good yeah
decent it's all right
yeah i've
[Laughter]
i've been i've been uh reading stuff
about this this this sort of thing uh
people say that you should kind of
ask yourself what what your body is
feeling right now and then the more you
do that the more you'll get used to
being like oh that feeling when my
stomach is a little bit like weird i i
would like to label it yeah or something
like that
um
have a go so so i actually had i had a
few days ago so i was i was out to
dinner with someone and then on the way
back to the car
realized that uh my bags had been stolen
from the car
and i was tracking them on like find my
because i had a apple air attack yeah i
was like
why am i well it's over there backpacks
over there the cars over there
um and i had this
kind of
weird feeling in the pit of my stomach
and i i realized that oh
this is like a feeling of anxiety of
like is my car still there have they
still in the car because they've got the
wallet and the wallet has kind the car
keys in it and so on and so on and then
i was like damn
i almost never feel this feeling and
then i was like damn i've got friends
who actually have anxiety and they feel
this all the time oh my god that's awful
so that was like the thought process for
this
because that was a very specific kind of
bodily feeling that i could identify as
being anxiety
like right now um
the feeling that i have is
i am
[Music]
happy glad like enjoying this
conversation i think it's been really
nice
there's a part of me that's
self-conscious because i know that every
time i'm on camera i sweat and so i'm
trying not to let the pit stains show on
the camera and all that kind of stuff
i'm also feeling a bit like
i don't know how i describe it but like
um
given that i am called the interviewer
in this sort of trying to stay one step
ahead of where the conversation is going
and thinking okay
where are we getting to next while at
the same time thinking that you're doing
a great job of like maintaining i'm
maintaining eye contact and being like
very engaging and so
if i'm half in my mind about where's the
conversation going next
maybe my
i'm coming across as less interested
than i actually am because i'm having a
great time internally i thought you were
completely bored
um and then at the same time like
because the camera's on and i have like
a resting board face i've been told it's
like
you know
like i did an interview the other day
and i was watching back myself and i was
like why do i look like i'm having the
worst time because i was having a great
time yeah and so it's like let me like
make my face uh sort of into a more like
interested kind of face which is not my
default kind of thing like i've actually
noticed you doing that during this
conversation oh really yeah i was
actually thinking about this like i
don't want to look my
because my default face is like this
yeah i feel like you i've had moments
during this conversation yeah i thought
you notice yeah that you look bored yeah
and then you like actively try and be
like yeah yeah and cute like happy
chappie i'm like oh like it's cute
you're like actively trying to listen
i've actively tried it no it's nice it's
like even when i'm looking bored i'm
actively listening but i'm just like
looking at this
people do i go on what did i say
yeah that's how i'm feeling right now
that's a good answer that's that
reasonable that anything good yeah okay
good
um was the question for that one i don't
remember what did you dislike about the
book writing
i don't know how we got onto that
um okay random says don't you think that
each student should have his own study
guide according to his skills and
potential
and not just one standard guide for
everyone
controversial controversial um yeah so i
was actually having a conversation this
morning about
how you know the whole when teach when
when students often ask teachers oh how
should i revise the teacher says
whatever works for you
and
to an extent yes
but also what works for humans is also
going to be good for you
so that's you know that's what i would
say to revision methods is that you know
there is science behind this stuff
there's the techniques which will work
for you and just because you haven't
tried them yet doesn't mean they won't
so while you might enjoy certain
techniques more at the end of the day
you know try these ones they they work
and i think the bit which is obviously
just me sharing my experience is the
staff on mental health the staff and
perfectionism and i'm very open that
that doesn't represent everyone and
their experiences
um yeah so if you want to write your own
study guide i'm so happy go ahead
i feel like it's kind of the same as
like working out in that yes everyone's
metabolism is different different genes
but like you know
if you if you follow the principles of
like you know eat at a caloric surplus
eat protein and aggressive overload you
will just get more hench and then all
the rest is kind of details like who
cares yeah
whereas with studying you follow the
principles of like space reputation
active recall taking care of your mental
health et cetera et cetera
you're gonna do okay you're gonna do all
right yeah it'll it'll be good um
azar says does your book talk about
imposter syndrome is it backed up by
science experience or anything anything
like that don't actually talk about
imposter syndrome i think i
very lightly touch on it um the last
chapter is kind of a more general
chapter because
it is it's about the future so i thought
you know my whole book is about studying
but so much of what you're studying is
what you're studying for and that is
often the future and i i talk about
odyssey plans and things which help me
because part of my motivation was
thinking about that future and if you
don't have a direction of where you're
going it's important to have that um
yeah so impossible syndrome is something
i touched on in that chapter but was
mainly backed up by my experience
not a
fair play um yeah what is the odyssey
plan for the uninitiated
oh the odyssey plan oh yeah this is so
cute as well i still remember i think
this is one of the first videos of mine
that you commented on
oh yeah yeah um i made a video about
odyssey plans and ali was just like oh
this is really great
oh thank you that's just really nice
thanks um yes so it's a really useful
framework i think it was designed by
yale it was yale stanford stanford
stanford yeah yeah yeah so stanford
university used this to help students um
yeah work out what they want to do with
their lives and the idea is that you
create different versions of how your
life could go so if you were to go
exactly on this current path you're on
studying what you're studying how would
your life look in five years so if
you're studying medicine you're probably
going to be a doctor or junior doctor
[Music]
yeah and then you do a second odyssey
plan which is what if you picked an
alternative path what if you decided to
study something you're considering but
not doing right now how could your life
look and then lastly you imagine if
societal expectations didn't matter
money didn't matter
how would your life look in five years
what would you be doing and then when
you sit back you can take some elements
from this life that you would have if
nothing else mattered and sort of put
that into the life that you're actually
gonna have
yeah so i i first saw your video on this
i think at the end of 2019
ish yeah um and it like genuinely shaped
sort of the things that i was doing with
my life from that point onwards because
i just never thought of thought of it in
that way before
um what does
like how how often do you do this like
what does what is your like five-year
what does he plan kind of look like
um i don't do it overly consistently i
think part of it comes into the whole
manifestation thing that we were talking
about is being aware of
things you'd like to attract into your
life um
but right now
i know that during university i've
changed so much already
like from first year to now how i view
youtube how i am as a person how to view
the world after traveling it's just
constantly changing so such that i
don't have a very consistent five-year
plan and that's fine with me so i think
this is something i'm going to revisit
in like final year
when i'm you know closer to that stage
but right now i'm just enjoying my life
let me enjoy my life
it's all good
um we've got mutt who says how do i get
a copy of the book
oh okay so you can get it on any any uk
book retailers so wh smith waterstones
or amazon oh is it uk only um currently
yes oh interesting yeah why didn't you
go for international um it's something
that i'd like to do but the publisher
i'm with is like a medium-sized
publisher so it's kind of like testing
it out in the uk yeah yeah it's done
pretty well in the uk so it's done
really well yeah probably going to get
america international the whole shabbat
yeah that's saying we're in disguise
which is really cool yeah wow
um so you're gonna be an international
bestseller
i mean let's manifest it exactly
um okay uh lsv says what's your most
useful advice for someone going to uni
this september other than to get the
book oh yeah definitely yeah of course
it's gonna happen okay i would say
that uni is a good time to be messy to
like work out so many things about your
life i think rather than going in and
like overly planning every minute of
your life at uni i would say try things
i'd say you know like make friends learn
about relationships learn about how you
learn learn about the subjects you like
join clubs just do your best to go out
of your comfort zone because i think
that's that's the best thing that uni is
for it's like
these few years of buying you time from
the rest of the world so yes study hard
but also
i don't know try stuff out i don't know
i'd probably give the same advice for
people who've just graduated uni as well
like i think we think of uni as being
the time where you should be messy but
actually
all of your 20s are reasonable it's time
reasonable time
yeah a lot of people even say into your
early 30s you don't really need to have
stuff figured out
um you need to start figuring stuff out
once you have like a family and kids to
support yeah but until then like okay
just to kind of do stuff
i need to take that advice better myself
um
uh what helped motivate you to study the
most during a levels
oh
um
[Music]
so many things one thing
i think firstly i really loved learning
and i really value learning so
that was like kind of an intrinsic
motivation to get me to want to do well
is because i wanted to learn um but
secondly i wanted to get into a good
university
so that was like a really really good
motivator of course boring but
true so we've got a few questions about
productivity then a few questions about
life um to close things off so
uh pripra 25 says how has your
relationship with productivity changed
over the last few years so much i used
to overly care well we're defining
productivity in the like toxic hustle
culture
economic output economic output
relativity yeah um
i was that typical cared too much about
grades all a star person at school my
life was just studying
and
yeah i felt very guilty for taking time
off and i think that was also how i felt
about the algorithm back then oh yeah
yeah you know like if i take time off
from the algorithm it it's not going to
be good
and i think i just have a much healthier
relationship to
grades
learning um
yeah like i redefined productivity in
what we were saying earlier and
i don't know just find more enjoyment in
life
nice
yeah sort of rambly um
natasha says how do you stay focused on
your goals
oh
breaking them down into many smaller
sub-goals it's really hard to stay
committed to one thing unless you make
it tangible yeah definitely um and
angs05 says what would you say keeps you
motivated to wake up early every day
what i'm doing
um it depends i have at least one day a
week where i wake up at 5 a.m bloody
hell because it's just i don't know it's
like my reset day i tend in summer it
changes because i have the flexibility
um but yeah
what makes me wake up early i feel
better i just feel good when i wake up
early it's like i have a longer day i'm
more productive i'm less likely to do
the thing where i just stay in bed and
watch youtube and go down a rabbit hole
and feel bad um yeah so do you wake up
early
how how do you balance the sort of need
for eight hours of sleep with the desire
to wake up early i never have less than
eight hours sleep or less than seven
hours sleep like i really sleep matters
to me okay um some days you wake up at 5
am you're sleeping
like
okay yeah so it's not a decision you
make in the morning it's a decision you
make at night definitely a decision oh
okay sure because i always try doing it
as a decision i make in the morning
come on where's the motivation no oh my
god mornings start at night for sure you
know what i was saying like if i want to
do a yoga video tomorrow putting it on
my youtube screen that night and then
going to bed knowing that i just roll
out of bed when i've got no motivation
it's just there and you just click it on
the thing you just do it yeah okay
morning start tonight it's good advice
um and now a few questions about life so
um alva says how have your aspirations
changed since after your a levels um
i think i was always five-year plan
person
have everything defined go from point to
point to point
um
and now i'm a lot more in the present my
aspirations are
to just enjoy myself and learn about
myself through
you know
friendships relationships um
like i don't know say there's like a
drama show like a theater performance or
something that my friend wants me to go
to
you know in the past i might have said
no because i was going to do some
something related to my goals that
evening oh but being more flexible now
and saying let's you know jade
this is valuable too that's interesting
that's interesting
i've been thinking about because i i
feel like when i was at
school and university for me
the work stuff was always the lowest
thing on the priority list
and so if there was ever like a so like
i made it a point when i when i got to
university that i was never gonna say no
to a social event for the sake of work
yeah um
and then that actually will like work
surprisingly well um the the the thing
that that ended up cutting out of my
life was watching tv by myself
when work became my default activity
rather than watching tv by myself
suddenly i had time to do all the things
i wanted to
and also like keep up with work but just
not watch tv by myself so yeah yeah and
how much did you miss it for watching tv
zero there you go yeah occasionally
people are like oh my god you've never
seen the office and i'm like i don't
have an either yeah
okay zahid says oh how do you get over
public criticism
oh god that's a tough one what sort of
public criticism do you get
right
so what's it look like like apart from
you look like a horse or whatever no for
example i had a lot of what is it these
days criticizing me for studying abroad
during the pandemic oh really yeah a lot
of people saying why are you going to
korea you know and i think it's hard
when i see criticism having a valid
point that's when i really struggle with
it because
i'm like wow like you know you're sort
of questioning
decisions
like what yeah yeah um
and so that was quite hard because it's
part of my degree you know all my
friends are going to it's something that
i sort of predefined and that the
pandemic was doing well
in doing well like it wasn't as bad in
korea um
and that was obviously a really hard
time for me when i got that criticism
because i was in quarantine in south
korea alone like in this room just with
the world's criticism about me going to
korea
and yeah and it made me really like
doubt my doubt my decision to go
but then now that i look back yeah
like would i have preferred to to stay
at home in lockdown
um
doing doing uni with the time difference
of like 10 hours
uh when i could have gone as part of my
degree like i think a lot of people in
the same situation would have gone too
yeah and if you're quarantining it's
like and it's
safe like it's just it's literally what
are people complaining about um
but yeah i think it yeah it's hard i
think it's just like being like coming
back to why you make choices yeah and as
long as it's valid to you in your life
then like
the criticism is fine yeah definitely
what so would you say your main
criticism is the toxic productivity
stuff or do you also get criticism one
of the things um the toxic productivity
stuff and recently
um because i've appeared in a bunch of
sheen's video videos i did a couple of
videos with elizabeth
um
there was a lot of criticism that oh wow
ellie's a real arrogant narcissistic
prick in these videos and like he
doesn't even he doesn't even look at
them when he's speaking to them he looks
at the camera instead what a dick and
stuff like oh the way he was coming
across was so condescending you can
clearly tell that he doesn't have he
doesn't have a respect for them and
a lot of like
little things which people in the
comments were yeah it really did like
people in the comments were like
psychoanalyzing the hell out of this
like minor thing
and then just to a point i was like
maybe they have got a point like i don't
i don't feel any of these feelings that
they're describing that are feeling but
maybe it's unconscious maybe it's like
maybe i am just coming across as like
that's yourself right well these
comments are so well written and there's
multiple of them yeah yeah and that's
the thing because how you come across
yeah
it's it's it's so subjective it's so
subjective they don't know you and your
relationship with those people it's like
you know you could just judge from like
this little video you're watching right
now everything about us as people yeah
and then when you're reading it you like
extrapolate it to yourself maybe that's
true is this
other people as well is this like you
know have my friends
think this way this is why this thing of
like how do i look when i'm i'm
listening to someone rather than when
i'm speaking it's like really in my mind
of like i need to not look as if i'm
bored because then people are going to
be like oh i was clearly bored during
this yeah yeah yeah um when i was doing
those like remote deep dives like the
one we did because i'd have the webcam
above me and i'd be looking at the
comments my eyes would always be
pointing downwards and the comments
would be like oh you stopped looking
board pay attention i'd be like oh
you're like trying too hard no idea what
it's like trying to run a live stream
like comment splitting
all this kind of stuff but to someone's
when someone's watching that it it
genuinely does look like i'm bored and
so it's all all this sort of stuff
that kind of got to me because it did
have a point yeah and especially like
the way we come across is it it is
actually someone's subjective
perspective yeah um but yeah it's also
when it touches on an insecurity you
know and they don't know that
necessarily there's an insecurity for
you but those comments stay in your head
and especially when they like start to
shape your behavior or how you do things
in future videos like
yeah what can you do all right we've got
three more um kieran says what does a
perfect day look like to you
oh uh
oh my gosh
okay i would do my morning routine
because i love my routine it sets up a
perfect day for me so
i would do my yoga my meditation um
preferably outside
in nature with some beautiful weather
i'd have my porridge because i just
genuinely really like that breakfast um
and then i think i would spend half the
day alone and half the day with friends
half the day like
walking
or i noticed in nature in my on my own i
feel amazing
and then
on the beach with friends and then you
know like when you're looking at the
stars having deep chats oh love that
that's a perfect day fireside chats what
about you
mine would be um
get up
and do some kind of
writing journaling type thing in the
morning
then do some sort of like sports things
maybe tennis with friends or like a
squash lesson or i was actually thinking
about this um when i was i was like
genuinely trying to plan out my life in
london like what does my perfect day
look like and i was thinking okay so
after the tennis lesson it's nine
o'clock go to the office co-working
space to hang out with team have a few
like content brainstorm sessions and
stuff and then in the afternoon probably
do one of these sorts of podcast
interviews because i really like doing
these because you can like really go
deep
normally
i don't know there's something weird
about having microphones in front of you
that like
encourages people to elaborate more on
their thoughts than they would feel
comfortable doing in real life so i
really like that then i would do some
sort of other activity probably 5 6 p.m
and then do dinner with friends
um followed by maybe board games with
friends and then like have like an hour
of reading in bed before that's lovely
that would be a pretty sick routine
energy i can make that happen yeah it's
like very doable actually like how lucky
you know that you can shape your life
around what a perfect day looks like in
yeah it's insane awesome like 100
um vb privilege
okay um
rug mini says how can one accept failure
and move on in life i think time firstly
is just amazing for accepting anything
yeah i bring back my classic oxford
rejection which i think yeah if you guys
don't know i was rejected from oxford
university um and that was really tough
for me at that time but now that i look
back
i'm so happy with my life you know
um i think again reframing what failure
is failure is just productive it's you
know it's
going on for like future success um it's
just something you can learn from
and yeah i think seeing it like almost
like zooming out imagine yourself and
then physically zooming out to see
everything your whole life the entirety
of the world and then seeing this tiny
thing that you've done is just really
insignificant
very nice um and then the final one
we've got from instagram is uh from
rohan who says
describe life in three words
oh my god i hate questions like this
okay
fluctuating okay that's a good one
you have to contribute one now okay
fun
oh no can i change it full of potential
for the potential yes oh okay three
words full of potential full of
potential nice potential for good
potential for bad
potential for amazing incredible things
just full of potential that's what life
is fantastic
um
great stuff that's uh seems like a good
place to leave things thank you for
coming on the podcast thank you so much
for having me we don't quite have a name
yet i think we're thinking of calling it
just
deep dive which was the name that the
old version was but yeah people voting
on it yeah
i'm gonna get people to like design some
logos for it and stuff uh but this has
been great guys everyone get the book
link in the video description if you
want to check it out and do you have
like a an email list or something for
people in international i actually i
don't okay no
just we'll put a google form or
something you can put your email address
in if you want to find out more about
this or something oh yeah no that's cool
yeah
but yeah thanks for coming on and
thanks for listening everyone and we'll
see you later